e
all right the time being 10:08 I would
like to get started with today's work
session and I will open the work session
on Senate Bill
324 and I think we have a an amendment
from representative PL hand it out
representative PL yeah during uh the
public hearing on Senate Bill 324 the
Lottery Commission had a concern that
they uh annunciated uh that uh this
should apply only the annual licenses
like a small like a quarter or less of
their uh LIC licenses are are monthly or
quarterly it just wouldn't work and so
they and so I have an amendment here
that uh strikes the sentence and adds a
similar sentence at least 45 days prior
to the expiration of an annual license
issued in accordance with this chapter
the commission shall notify the
licensing of the pending expiration so
it clearly applies only to annual
licenses now they said they they have to
do this anyway under RSA 541 a29 and 541
a30 this refers spe explicitly to 541
830 I did leave a uh a request on their
uh website email uh and I never got an
answer but this did Cover what uh I
think the the concerns were in
hearing thank you representative
shamberg uh representative PL uh your
last in lines 13 and 14 of the amendment
are different than lines 12 13 and 14 of
the original Bill uh you reduced
something there is that because you put
it in
the sentences above on six and seven and
eight well let me get the original Bill
all
right all I did was insert a couple of
lines that's it no no no well that's
what I did what what the drafters did
another
story all
right but talks about the
re revoking or suspending under this
section by the commission no less than
45 days before such revocation or
suspension well it it's by referring to
541 830 all of that's there the
commission okay huh all
right it refers to a different
RSA thank
you
okay so the notification looks like the
notifications been moved up okay well
the notification is still 45 days but uh
it's refers only to annual licenses
right okay represent Aly thank you are
are there any licenses that are two
years or
more not to my knowledge but uh I see
the people here so they can respond I
see Valerie
King good morning my name is Valerie
King I'm with New Hampshire lottery um
there are no two-year
licenses I did want to point out one
thing um we we have been in
Communications with um senator alesandro
to make sure that any changes we made
were um met his satisfaction as well the
draft that we received did include the
additional language the at least 45 days
but it still had the next sentence which
reads the commission shall notify lenses
licensed under
RSA um that that refers to the
expirations the revocations that needed
to be struck because we can't give a
notification before it
happens um there's a copy of the a
redraft over there and glance through
that and see if you still have a
concern borrow
borrow yes that's correct what you have
in is correct now
yes um any other any other concerns
no thank you any uh anyone on the
committee have
a everyone's good okay thank you thank
you all right so no further comments
from the committee on uh
SB
324 okay saying n I'll close the uh work
session on SB
324 okay next I'll will open the work
session on speed
363 I don't think we have um an
amendment yes representative PL this uh
several years ago we got rid of
greyhound racing because of the abuse
that the animals were put under this
this eliminates uh the sill cast uh uh
for greyhound racing that's all it is
there is a economic a small economic
impact but to me it's it's uh it's got
to be small part of overall revenues and
we live up to our word uh about uh uh
the greyhound racing and the abuse of
the dogs are undertaking uh but we still
have uh horse racing which is fine
historic horse racing so I don't see a
problem but let's discuss
it comments concerns from the
committee might be on the same page all
right
looks like uh we agree on this
one okay thank you um I will close the
work session on sp sp
363 so that's going to
BEP all right next I will open the work
session on
SB
and representative PL I think uh you
have an amendment for that I do and this
amendment uh
came uh through the uh commission uh
through the from the commission through
uh through uh
Senator EXC me oh yeah through through
sen Senator Lang to me and so I just
Incorporated what I got and made the
amendment uh so uh the
uh words a strien of the books or
records of said person Association
Corporation which clearly show the
tickets titled to reimbursement in any
given race live s c or historic shall be
forwarded to the Lottery Commission such
money shall become a part of the special
fund establishing RSA 28421 J that
stricken uh also stricken vouter shall
be remitted to the state treasur on
January 3 31st of the calendar year 24
months after the year of the unclaimed
voucher added is honor before July 1 of
every year said person Association
Corporation shall submit to the treasure
a check for any unclaimed money during
the previous fiscal year along with a
gaming operator's written report for the
previous fiscal years unclaimed money
which shall automize both the unclaimed
tickets and vouches and the unclaimed
amounts there from a copy of the report
shall be forwarded to the Lottery
Commission for the first banial year
after the effective date of this section
the report shall cover both years of the
previous biennium Treasurer shall
deposit the unclaimed ticket and voucher
money in the governor's scholarship fund
and so that this did this work did not
come from me I was just a conduit
because it's now a house bill
yeah representa Aly I was under the
impression that most of us or all of us
wanted to get rid of the money going to
the governor's scholarship fund because
it's unconstitutional for one
thing and
um and we we ought to have the money
where it belongs in the education trust
fund we can't speak to that I I actually
have a note here that I I took during
the public hearing that with the words
delete um as as per what you're saying
yeah so that would be removing most of
line 22 and line 23 from
it oh if we struck the treasur so
deposit the unclaimed ticket and voucher
money in the governor scholarship fund
you you fine with the rest of
it and everybody else because I'll I'll
I'll ask okay
let's huh representative should be
specified the Ed education trust
fund I think it's automatic
representative um it I think it all
lottery money goes into the uh education
trust fund as I understand it um if uh
director wants to speak to that that
would be fine and helpful I'm
sure
um um good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Charlie
McIntyre executive director H Audy with
me is John con our chief compliance
officer um well you want to speak John
oh I I sure I could speak speak to that
I know at the um there were numerous
questions at the public hearing
about um some inconsistencies within the
statutory language I know there's also
the discussion uh about the source of
where the funds would go to um we worked
with Senator Lang to try to clean up the
language as best we could um to make
sure everything was consistent um with
respect to uh the um obviously trying to
to effectuate what um Senator Lang was
trying to do in his original bill Senate
bill um we addressed we took out the
Lang language with regard to um RSA 28
the fund for RSA 284 21j um left in the
um the language regarding the governor's
uh scholarship fund um obviously that's
so what we were just trying to do is
clean up the language as Senator Lang
intended it coming out of the
Senate now to we oh sorry just sorry to
interrupt also at the uh public hearing
there was a discussion regarding uh the
constitutionality of moving the money to
the governor's scholarship fund we did
reach out to the Department of Justice
and I know they are currently working on
an opinion um on that issue
specifically uh wait a minute let me go
to representative spillsbury
first
you yeah I would concur with the
amendment provided that that last
sentence is removed and I also wanted to
ask so just to clarify what was said a
moment ago so does that then mean that
the sentence such monies shall become a
part of the special fund establish in
RSA 28 does that have to go back in what
does that specifically refer to yeah so
it doesn't it can certainly be put back
in that it specifies that it goes to the
education trust fund certainly in the
absence of any specific language uh any
revenues that would come to us would go
to the education trust fund um so so it
merely clarifies what would otherwise be
true as a default matter correct
okay representative PL okay if we struck
that about going to the governor
scholarship fund won't give you
heartburn at
all we we don't make a decision on where
the money goes uh as as my boss likes to
say we we only make the money and then
we hand it over to you and uh it's up to
you to decide where it should go or your
colleagues down the
hall I didn't at least your colleagues
down the hall that in finance yeses Aly
yes um I believe this bill doesn't have
to come out until May
16th could we just wait for the
Department of
Justice if I could representative to
that to that point uh we did speak with
the assistant AG yesterday actually
about this and he said he's about three
quarters done so I'd imagine it would be
days not
weeks resident plat though I understand
the sentiment if you don't like it you
don't like it no matter what the AG says
and so if you don't like it let's get
rid of it
yeah good point uh yes representative
Ames yeah I I support what
representative PL just said I think that
uh that
uh all
lottery funds after
expenses have flowed into the education
trust fund that's what you advertise
that's the expectation that's my
expectation our expectation I think and
it seemed seems to be quite clear to me
that that's what the Constitution
expects and so uh I don't I don't think
we need to wait and let's get you know
it's nice to get some things done and um
move moved out of out of our purview so
this is one opportunity for that
representative shamberg followed by
fellows yes a question for the director
um the the the definition Lottery of uh
tickets and things like this that was
established in what
1964 is that different than what
paramutual and uh what's the other term
here unclaimed tickets is that a
separate definition that that can go
somewhere else besides into the
education trust fund well we certainly
looking at we'll give you the the
history of it obviously a lot sweep
Stakes commission was passed in 1963
implemented in ' 64 and it was a very
specific sweep Stakes
ticket we added a number of games those
all became traditional lottery tickets
in the 70s and 80s we added scratch
tickets we added Powerball in 1986 all
those were TR traditional lotteries and
then in 1990 was codified in the
Constitution the specific language that
representative Ames was referring to
regarding revenues of Lottery minus
expenses equals education trust fund
thereafter after the paramutual the
former paramutual commission which then
became the racing and child beginning
commission was merged with Lottery we
absorb them and so their
revenues is not defined by Lottery
traditionally as per history of the
legislation of the state and so that's
why we're asking an opinion not just for
this matter which is helpful but
certainly for going forward what is the
because that wasn't part of the of us in
1990 when the Constitutional amendment
was passed
represent
fellows thank you on the amendment I
just have a question about lines 8
through 11 that are crossed out now so
um for the the first part of it about
records currently it says records have
to be submitted to the lottery and
that's crossed out did you cross that
out because you don't want the that or
that that is true that's we're trying
simplify the process so this
is currently the process is that we
receive books and records of uncleaned
vouchers and then we hold them on our
books for a prolonged period of time uh
for people to to be able to come and
reimburse them this is to streamline
this to set a set time period where
people can get reimbursed at the
property um and then just essentially
send the check over to us rather than
have us be a part of the reimbursement
process
just follow up follow up
so um I would think that this might play
some kind of role in ensuring that they
send you all the money that you should
be getting or you have how are you going
to know that we still have several other
um statutory authorities to be able to
audit those funds and those books in
order to ensure that we're getting full
amount um so they don't actually need to
produce those over to us um we have
other other powers that allow us to
ensure that we're getting everything
that the state is entitled
to yes represent
elberger thank you Mr chair so when we
get to Executive to the executive
session would it be or should I wait
till then to ask I'm just wondering from
a procedural perspective that if we
don't like that last sentence on lines
2020 22 and 23 in the amendment can we
just uh amend the amendment to remove
that line no uh we we were
representative PL has made a request to
get a new um Amendment drafted and we
hopefully we'll be able to get that it
will be in time for us to exec all right
thank
you in
theory Mr yes representative Southworth
um so just point of order do you need a
straw vote to say that let's we want uh
represent PL to do that or are we all
set
um I think we're all set do you have an
objection it sounds like the best idea
representative PL did
it wow thank
you all
right representative spilburg yeah just
to clarify um if we are dropping the
sentence on line 22 and 23 aren't we
also reinstating the sentence on line 10
and
um I don't know um so well we can ask
her witness again but I I believe that's
what I heard such money shall become a
part of the special fund established in
RSA 28421 J I don't have um the ability
to look up that citation right now but
I'm assuming that's what we want Mr coni
do you have a
or that's that is the education trust
fund that's the the account that holds
over to educ trust and if I recall
correctly representative this language
was added when racing was merged with us
so it make clear where the Fone month's
funds would go because they weren't
originally part of Lottery that's
probably so given that history I think
it's important to
clarify okay representative PL I have a
concern with cross referencing of
rsas if RSA
28 for for 21j exists that's where it's
going whether or not this Rec this
refers to
it well I think it's a fine point but
given the history and the fact that this
activity was not originally part of the
Lottery Commission when the
Constitutional amendment was uh adopted
I just think that this is uh it removes
all
doubt so yeah um okay yes represent
fellas I'm unclear about this discussion
I thought I assumed that the 20 28 4 21
is the governor's scholarship fund no
it's not the it's not the trust fund the
TR I um it it's not the trust fund it is
the fund that the the treasurer holds
for lottery funds uh in order to hold
that that's where our funds sit and our
expenses get paid out of the Overflow
from that that account then goes into
the education trust fund oh okay so
we shouldn't take that out so you would
recommend that that come back in I if if
the intent of the committee is to ensure
that the money is going to flow as all
lottery monies flow it certainly would
be um I I would guess advisable to put
that back
in okay representative
lle so my understanding of what we're
saying saying now is that we're going
to we've cut the books or records of
said person we're going
to leave that sentence out yes because
we don't want them to have to deal with
the records but the second sentence that
says such monies shall become a part of
the special fund established in RSA
right we're going to keep that sentence
right got it okay yeah representative PL
uh Miss for did you hear the discussion
so thank you
perfect thank
you okay we all good all right thank you
very
much and I'll close the uh work session
on S SP
okay I'm going to open the work session
on SB
454 and with that just note to the
committee that this is the one early
Bill we have all the other bills are are
not early bills so far that we have uh
in
committee discussion on um 454 represent
Mr chair I didn't hear what you said
it's the only Bill that it's the only
early Bill uh oh thank you that we have
so it has to be out uh what is it April
16th I believe uh no a APR yeah I think
it is April
16th I know it's April 16th I can tell
you in uh yeah is it April 16th April
25th actually no it's May 16th that the
other bills have to be up oh yeah April
25th April
25th so we have we have plenty of time
but I want to make note of that there's
no reason to delay if we know what we
want to do with it representative Aly Mr
chairman I'm I would
like to have the little bit of time that
we've got until then in terms of
revenues to try to see what
is actually happening to the business
profit
tax okay uh representative spillsbury
I'm curious to what committee will this
go
Finance
definitely and it we're being told that
it is because of the extra refunds the
extra refunds are above
by that amount what the Dr thought they
would be this
year and we'd set it up thinking that
okay most of those refunds aren't going
to start hitting us for a while so that
we can adapt to
it and I don't know how much that is I'd
like to get the Dr in here to talk to us
about that and whatever else is going on
with the business profits
tax maybe we can get a yes
representative spillsbury yeah this is
454 right yes so this deals with the
allocation of real estate transfer taxes
and I'm missing what the connection is
to the
refunds well BPT I think uh changing
going from five million to 10 million I
think well represent Al me I'll let you
talk to
it half of about half of that money
comes out of the general fund and about
half of that money comes out of the
ETF and finance The Well Finance could
next year if we're in TR real
trouble
um uh in the budget uh undo this but
that's the only way they could could uh
handle if they need that five
million or other things that are just as
important I'm just not getting the
connection what refunds into the
business profit tax have to do with the
real estate transfer
tax M sorry the business profits tax uh
and the business Enterprise tax uh that
we're seeing in the
um the statements about how much tax
money is coming in
on are the business profits tax is sh
showing a
considerable
um reduction due to
refunds
and it's but when the
Dr figured out what we thought we'd be
getting this year and they included what
they thought the refunds would be under
the new system that we had developed two
terms ago to try to cut down the excess
money sitting there that we that they
could the businesses could take at any
time and they're saying that this is due
to the refunds but it's excess refunds
above what our
um our estimates had been in the
budget
representative leapley followed by
PL thank you Mr chair um I just wanted
to confirm that that this time would be
appropriate to ask a question to
Dr are we in work session on this bill
yeah we we can uh let me go to we'll do
that shortly okay thank you go to
representative PL I think the
relation representative alme still
didn't hit it but the relation is
overall taxes and uh it I keep track of
whether we're Surplus or negative and
all that overall taxes we hit a high of
about $106 million since then in March
it's been
less uh we we've had a hit and it's been
negative in March and I think overall
we're about 50 5 somewhere in the $56
million range Surplus which could
continue to disappear and the concern is
if we're taking an extra 5 million uh
and putting it into uh from Real Estate
transfer tax into a special fund does
that leave enough money elsewhere to
fund state government and
so that's a general relation if it's
just a a matter of observing about
overall you shortages and concerns I
concur yeah I don't think this bill is
wise and and uh especially since the uh
let's is that what in fact you were
trying to drive
at are you talking about representative
Aly yes representative Aly please um
am I interpreting you correctly yes I am
am worried that if we put it in the
special fund then the finance
committee can undo it in the budget but
that's kind of a last minute when people
have been expecting to have it um that
they would be
doing and if things are
okay there will probably be a lot of
interest
in on in put giving them that five
million yes and I think this was similar
to according to the notes I took similar
to our concerns during the public
hearing and
um you know s similar conclusion uh
representative fellows so I would just
like to add to that my I I have have the
same
concern um about you know reducing
what's available in the general fund and
also the education trust fund but in
addition to that I would just like to
add that putting the first5 million into
that um
affordable housing fund was only done in
20120 so you know takes a while for
things to get started we don't even know
what kind of impact that's having so I
think it would be prudent if we're going
to start putting $10 million into a fund
that we really want to hear exactly what
what benefit uh that has right
representative Southworth uh thank you
um for clarification um representative
alme are you thinking we should wait
perhaps till like the second week of
April or something we'll have more
information by
then I'm just wondering about the
timeline yeah well the latest we could
wait would be the third week in April
that's to really tight to the 25th on
well no we have to have it out of here
on the 25th that's right um that is
really not an I mean as I mean we are
fairly far be we're some 26 million or
so behind on the business profits tax
right now but in the next 5 days it
hasn't happened in the past but in the
next 5 days it could my God could mostly
disappear
and the same thing would be happening in
April uh so we won't we I think we're
talking about having a revenue
reestimate in May but uh and that's
really the first time we can be fairly
sure what's going on
um so yeah I would I would agree I think
two weeks uh is probably not going to
make that much of a difference in terms
of figuring that out um I know there's a
lot of questions let me invite Dr up um
if you guys would come
up Mr chair yes R just for our
scheduling the 15th is the Monday and of
the beginning of the first week or the
third week in April so we have the
entire rest of that week and Dr should
have um a pretty good idea of what
they're because 15th is a deadline for
their filing so we've got four days
anyway in in the third week and the 25th
is
then uh the Thursday of the next week I
mean my I I understand that my my
concern would be that
um you know that that isn't going to
make a trend if we see some sort of
trend now I'm not sure that one more uh
point is going to give us enough to
decide one way or the other my sense is
no matter what whether we wait we're
still going to probably reach the same
conclusion but let's ask Dr how we're
doing um with our revenues right now hi
good morning my name is Lauren o solivan
I'm the senior Financial Analyst at the
Dr I'm Wendy mtiv you're a financial
analyst at
Dr and we're here to answer any
questions so um I was following along
with the conversation but is there a
specific specific question that I'll do
my best to
answer well I guess the the question
first question would just be I'll ask
the first question and then we can go
from there would be um how are how are
revenues tracking at this point okay so
what I have in front of me right now is
today's um Cash basis revenue report
which is reporting revenues received to
business days ago so this is through
March
22nd and right now what we're looking at
um the business taxes um month to date
are $35 million uh below the prior year
and $39 million below plan as of as of
that day um what's due this month are
the partnership returns and extension so
the majority of our filers they're not
due until April 15th so um we were
looking at some of those transactions
and it's a Confluence of different
things some of it they haven't filed yet
some of it these were one time tax
notices some of it uh they may be paid a
little bit less so it's it's a hodge
podge um the refunds are actually very
similar to last March and um and we
still have one more we have more refunds
coming out tomorrow and that will be the
last for this month so we'll have a
better sense how much of that is related
to the um credit carryovers but one
thing that um we've had noticed over the
course of the Year about half of those
refunds
we can attribute to the 500% cap being
in effect for um those credit carry
forwards well we notice a lot of many of
those uh taxpayers when they are taking
those refunds are taking more refund
than
um um how do I say this they could leave
up to 500% but they're taking more than
that so they're so they're leaving maybe
less than 100% of their liability as
credit on account who are only leaving
500% on account tend to be our smaller
taxpayers where they're where 500% of
their liability is less than $1,000 but
some of the bigger taxpayers are you
know so then when the 250 kicks in they
don't have that money sing on account it
came out essentially in the timeline a
little bit earlier than perhaps expected
okay is it fair to say that um two
numbers you mentioned was 22 million
below um last year uh that was um so
it's so for the month it's 35.7 below
and year to date it's 26.7 below okay
but the the year-to date month um
doesn't mean as much right now correct
because uh the majority of our taxpayers
will um their due date is April 15th
okay so this is just the Partnerships
all right represent
Aly thank you um
so the under
500% are not reacting yet which is what
we'd expected them to do to not
react on that well what it is if it's
below the 500% way they're taking a
refund um we we don't necessarily know
why someone would take a refund except
that I can tell you're well if you
didn't take a refund you're at the it's
because you're at the 500% you had to
take something yeah and what I know like
well if they only left 500% on account
it would be this much but they're taking
more than that so they're actually
taking those refunds sooner then perhaps
instead of keep instead of keeping more
of it on account to um take away from
future liability lowering those
estimates follow up so
for on what we did was draw their
attention to the fact that they had all
this money sitting here that they' never
taken
when we thought they'd just shave it
down that I I couldn't tell you exactly
what the motivation is I know there's
two ways you can they can request the
refund and if you don't request the
refund we will automatically if you're
at the 500% automatically refund you
that amount or we'll give you so many
days to make a decision through letters
and if you don't respond to the letter
then you will get a refund so there's
also that happening in the back um as
part of our processes to that is forcing
some of those refunds out of the
door but followup what we would have
been expecting when we were doing the
revenue estimates two years ago on would
have been that the 500
percenters on that we refunded would go
down to
300% with the
refund if you were just sending it back
to them you wouldn't send them the whole
500% you'd send them the 200% at the
top I would have to look into I I wasn't
here for when that was done so I'd have
to see if that was the thought process
at the time yeah and we don't really
know what the thought process they went
through was either so I do know we do
have processes in place that if you do
not request the refund or fill out that
part of the form and you're do a refund
you are given the opportunity to leave a
credit but if if you do not respond to
the letters we will issue the refund and
that is a pol and that is actually a
policy decision that was made so that's
also impacting that that's outside of
the CCL thank
you do you know what the time frame for
I think the next step down was um
250% or is it three I think it's tax
here 25 to
250 okay do you know oh in 25 in for for
tax year 25 so 25 okay so that would
probably be due in like
I don't have that in front of me I
didn't come prepared to talk about
business taxes today so I don't have
that information in front of me so I if
I we can send you that information as a
reminder of how that phase out yeah that
I mean that's more affecting us in the
future yeah uh representative PL and
then spillsbury yes I I can't remember
the bill number we had a house bill
earlier this year we had that this tax
cut that tax cut another tax cut all all
in one big uh wrapped up in a big red
bow and we decided with that that uh uh
individually those tax cuts may have
Merit in the future might but we have to
have a a revenue we'd have to have a a a
a revenue year a budget year uh so we
could take an overall look at revenues
before we decided anything and I I see
this as the same thing I I like the
sentiment of increasing another $5
million I like the sentiment into the uh
affordable housing but I just think the
timing is wrong we we our revenues are
not extremely robust for year to date
overall they're still a positive uh even
though but but despite the business
profit tax but not by a huge amount and
expect that we just don't have a it's
not robust enough for me to feel
comfortable doing anything till next
year and so I'm going to suggest interim
study yeah and I would also add to that
that until we see those April returns
and extension come in it's really hard
to gauge even even for the interest in
dividends tax that's when the bulk of
the revenue comes
in okay uh representative spelsbury
followed by leapley followed by Ames
thank you Mr chairman I to refocus on
what specifically SB 454 proposes I'd
like to make two
observations number one no tax revenue
Source has taken a deeper hit in this uh
current fiscal year um uh as real estate
transfer tax it's not close and my sense
of the market given the sustained High
mortgage interest rates is that it's not
about to recover uh anytime very soon my
second
observation is that the effective date
proposed here is July 1st 2025 so I
would just itl this bill and uh see
where we are next
year
uh representative
leapley thank you Mr chair I have two
questions and then um two
observations my first
question deals with the I'm looking at
the monthly preliminary reports that we
get just because I want to ask a couple
questions about Rett to make sure I
understand okay um so I'm looking at the
real estate transfer tax um month to dat
the plan and then the difference MH and
there there there's the general fund
column there's the education fund column
and then there's a Jen and Ed together
column so is is does half of R go to the
general and half go thir a third goes to
the education trust fund
okay and so a third to education trust
fund and twoth thirds to the general
fund yes and this bill just says from RE
Vue
collected so the way that uh it
currently works that 5 million comes out
of the general fund portion so that's
where the transfer occurs on the current
on the five million right
now so um my expectation is that if
we're increasing the amount and nothing
else changes it would still come from
the same place that's where the transfer
would occur I'd have to look behind the
scenes if there's any back calculations
because once we put something in the
education trust fund we generally don't
take the money out to we hold it in
trust for
Education yeah we like what if we put
into too much we leave it there okay
it's not for housing it's for Education
um the other question I had is just to
make sure I'm reading this right so when
I look at the r for the general fund it
says month to date 9.5 million is that
receipts so yeah that's receipts um net
of refunds that's the 9462 number you're
looking at I mine says
9.5 um and then the next it says plan
7.0 so for this month for this
fund it's ask which which one this is
the thing I got in the email that we
get oh is that the one from Department
of admin
Services uh yes ah okay so maybe it's
less precise than yours I'm not worried
about like Point whatever I just want to
make sure I understand so it looks to me
I'll say what I understand you correct
me so it looks like real estate transfer
tax month to date 9.5 million the plan
was 7.0 I'm talking about the Gen oh
okay fund so that's 2.5 million
over just for that month right and then
if I look across over to the education
fund it says um 3.4
and I guess there's not really a month
to date because you're transferring it
from the other account that so that's
correct so what you're seeing um those
transfers to the education trust fund
occur on the last business day of the
month so essentially if you want to
think about all the money stops in the
general fund first and then it's
calculated what goes to the education
trust fund and this is true for all
taxes except for utility property tax
which 100% goes to the education trust
fund and then at the end of the month
the amounts that belong to education
trust fund then we uh do a general
ledger entry to move that so what you're
looking at now on your month to date
you're probably seeing a zero for the
education trust fund that does that
education trust fund piece is in the 9.5
million so if you take a third of that
okay that's what as of today that's what
would go to the education trust fund so
now I want to back out because I just
had the monthly numbers and so it was
helpful for me to understand so to back
out I'm wondering um what where I
received re for R last year as opposed
to this year like just total receipts
for the year oh for the whole year so
for Rett was um 200 so this is net of
the affordable housing fund transfer so
29.2 million and then just add back five
million to that that was 20 that was
and the on a cash basis so that may not
and year to date for this year I guess
that is year to date for this year so
year to date this year and so that's
through March 22nd is 140.6 million and
at this time last year it was 168.3
Million okay um so the reason I ask all
of this you have one more one more
question I want to get
other so I just um so I've been asking
questions of Dr and this is a work
session and others have given their
takeaways and what we should do with
this bill so I'm going to give my
takeaway now that I've gotten the
information I needed um so if I
understand correctly when this was
established in 2020 it was $5
million if we adjust for inflation
only right if we were giving them
exactly the same amount of dollars today
it would be6 million so what we're
talking about is $4
million and I understand you rais a good
point about tax cuts and should hold off
tax cuts are like a huge unknown right
we don't know how much revenue we're
giving up with a tax cut with this bill
we're talking about basically in real
money $4 million that's a very small
amount when we talk about the New
Hampshire
budget hi hi um so we're talking about
homelessness right this is a solution
for
homelessness which is linked with
joblessness which when we have homeless
people in the state it's very expensive
because they need other
services not only do they need other
services they're often not going to work
so their employers and they themselves
are paying less taxes so I think we're
thinking about the problem backwards
we're asking ourselves if we have enough
money to pay for this expense and I
think we should be asking ourselves the
opposite question do we want Revenue in
the future if so we should make this $4
million investment today in building
houses in the state that are affordable
so let's just be real clear on what
we're talking about we're talking about
$5
million thank you okay
um representative a wait a minute Ames
representative Ames did
you no but he had his hand raised
before
um yeah much at the line of thinking
that I I've been following is uh was
captured by representative Le's line of
questions so um I I just wanted to say
that uh in terms of the timing for this
bill this is the time for this bill
because um the housing need is urgent
and uh this is a program that from a
policy perspective the house has
embraced and uh um the implementers of H
housing
policy uh the people who are on the
ground trying to get to a better place
with our afford particularly our
affordable housing um say that this is a
bill that will help uh move the needle
on that and uh and we need to move that
needle as soon as possible and that will
in turn um likely help with our economy
e and help with our revenues and in
terms of delay um you know I'm I'm okay
with uh slowing down a little bit to see
what more we can see but I've been
through this for many years and um is
there's always uncertainty and always uh
uh ups and downs in the various taxes
that are imponderable you can't figure
it out uh April's a big Revenue month
historically for um interest dividends
well that's a smaller tax now and uh for
um the business taxes uh but a lot comes
in after that so you still got a big
question mark about what's going to be
there for the year and um and so uh
we'll be better informed true if we wait
a little bit but uh we won't be fully
informed we it will still be a guessing
game um an educated guessing game that's
what it is and we'll all be uh uh
steered in our guessing by our own um
policy preferences I'm sure uh like it
or not we're not totally objective and
um and then we'll come we'll be a little
better informed I'll say that and uh
maybe we'll that will uh lead to a a
better decision but for myself I'm ready
to go on this thing and uh
um but I want to get a good vote that
everybody's comfortable with so I'd be
okay with delaying uh in order to get
better
information representative ORS thank you
Mr chair so some thoughts on this having
done this my whole life first of all $5
million is a drop in the bucket second
of all I agree with representative
leapley if you want to have a housing in
the future affordable housing when we
have a housing crisis then why don't we
do it either way I really don't care you
know let's get on with it either pass it
or kill it I mean Jeepers this isn't
that difficult thank
you representative
Aly thank you
on I would not agree with itl because
interim study would allow the Senate on
towards uh after we have been able to
finish with the money items the Senate
to think which of their many priorities
they have apparently sent to the house
that on are going to reduce our our
rainy day uh not our rainy day fund but
the money that we can access our Surplus
to near Zero by the end of this term
um on and
on and I I do
I do not know where housing stands
within all of the things that they're
trying to get money
for on but
on if we did have is they would
presumably not engage in deficit
spending over there and they would have
to make up their minds whether they're
going to put this as an amendment onto a
bill and send it back to us that would
point I would very happily vote for it
but
um okay I'm just worried
about where we'll be next year if we
have almost no Surplus from this year
thank you
representative PL I sometimes have
cognitive dissonance and so I
recommended interim study I could also
see given some of the
discussion passing it but uh with the
idea that the finance committee will
take another shot at it and so if they
don't think the money is there uh they
can do something different with it I
could go either way well my
understanding is ways and
means we're we're charged with making
sure that we believe the money is there
Finance um needs to finance decides of
the money that's potentially there how
should it be distributed so um we we do
have um we should make sure that we feel
uh comfortable with the best way to move
forward as opposed to having another
committee decide that representative
ORS thank you Mr chair so my question is
thank you for taking my question if you
had to give us a swag as to where
revenues going in the future April May
June could you give us what your swag is
I can Define swag if you need it yeah I
would like that to find okay very
good so where do you think it's going
this is is re really tough to say
because I see because I'm seeing
surprises so it's hard to gauge is this
a oneoff am I seeing delay you know
something maybe didn't come in this
month but it's going to come in next
month I am seeing and I think I said
this in the testimony um during the
public hearing I'm feeling a little bit
more positive about Rett this is the uh
first this is like one of the first
months I've seen all fiscal year where
rent is actually growing I'm seeing the
transactions growing and while it's
currently a million under plan that's
probably the closest to plan we've been
all year and and that's where I so I'm
feeling more positive I'm not suggesting
though that we're going to have this big
recovery but I feel like we're we're
past the uh bottom but that's my own
personal opinion uh on that and um but
right now until I really see how this
month closes and and um it's really hard
to gauge what's happening right now with
the business taxes though indd has been
surprisingly strong this year too we I
had expected to see it come down now
that the rate was at 4% what they're
filing so I have to look at the
composition of who if this is um just
more people are filing that there's some
you know they people are doing well MH
so that that's so I I feel like it's a
mi I guess summarize that it's a mixed
bag okay thank you quick followup and so
do you believe that as we've cut taxes
revenues have stayed the same gone up or
down that's hard to gauge because there
were other things that were also
impacting it's not just the rate cut it
was moving to um to the single sales
factor it's going into the um you know
moving away from like the market Source
um way of attributing um what's taxable
income on some of those tax and that's
um some of those are very hard to
quantify if that was the motivation if
you look at it year-over-year the only
one that you can really look at as maybe
single sales Factor okay thank you yeah
representative duet yeah just real
briefly I I agree with uh representative
Aly and if there's ever been a a piece
of legislation that deserves an interim
study look it's this one right here
we're playing a game of days and weeks
in figures let's let's have the figures
come back and if if it is in fact a
priority for the other side of the wall
and we all agree that housing is a
priority let's not be hasteful in what
we do to make a deadline that we have to
make by by rule let's IAS this and and
do the right thing at the right
time okay I'm going to uh end the work
session on uh s SP
197 okay I'm going to open the work
497 and do we have a we have an
amendment
so is it passed out or it's a very small
Amendment and I did I did oh here it is
if you don't have it representative D
said is it I I
haven't uh would you like to speak to
the amendment represent the amendment
only does one thing on line eight it
changes
on completion of the federally acire
required disproportionate share with
compliance with the federally required
disourage here and we owe this one I
think to representative
Ames but I said I'd get the amendment
but
um okay I do I think understand
disproportionate share more than anyone
on this side of the
room most
likely okay uh any other comment on this
amendment the amendment fully replaces
does it not representative Aly or is it
a u the amendment or is it a section I'm
sorry section five yeah it's only
Section Five Section Five right the rest
of it stays the way it is yep makes
sense and that was the recommendation I
think during the public hearing as well
so that yeah is good any other comments
uh representative PL I'm sorry I don't
understand what's going on what what's
this amendment do uh so look at line
8 okay line eight used to say well line
eight of the amendment if you look at
line 15 of the bill line 15 of the bill
says comp uh the fourth word in
completion of so we're changing
completion of to line eight on the
amendment says compliance with so just
correcting that
one it wasn't correct to say say
completion of it's compliance with
that's why that that's been changed any
other questions
comments okay seeing none I'm going to
close the the work session on uh s SP
o all right I'm going to open the work
session on
sp513 and we have a couple of amendments
um one from representative fellows I
also have an
amendment
um which I should have passed out
sooner well I'm I'm
passing my Amendment
out yeah there should be as 25 of them
representative fellows do we already
have the amendment you did
or
have I don't think we have
yours you're you're do you have the
amendment your Amendment oh oh yeah pass
that around
please and then there
was okay and there was something else
that you had printed out right that you
showed me that document did you get
copies of
that I don't she
knows representative fellows do you also
have that other document
you so both of the Amendments that
you're looking at ref yeah hold hold on
a second not everyone has it
yet basic
uh
this is
definitely
for
okay I think everybody has uh all the
handouts you should have two different
amendments and then
um there's also just a third information
sheet that representative fellows um
passed out um let me first say that um
on on the amendment that that I have
here
um I received wording from Michael Haley
um his concern when he testified was
that um churches needed to be added to
the mix and so he um he rewarded this
and uh that so my my my Amendment
basically fixes that issue of uh making
sure that the churches were added to the
um to the m mix of um
Charities uh so let's first look at that
one representative Aly yes it looks like
what represent fellow is passed out
as as
background is pretty much the same as
what you've got in your
Amendment
all right um any other comments on my
amendment of that order we'll go
representative fellows yeah so
um I I don't
remember that somebody told us that
churches should be in here I yes yeah
Michael Haley charitable
trusts anyway so that was not my focus
what I was working on my Amendment
focused on um the sentence that if you
look at the
um the Senate the the amendment that we
got from the
Senate the sentence that was on
lines for the first sentence of
2A and my concern with that was on line
five the way it was worded it sounded as
if the charity
organization needed a license and this
is not about they're as far as I know
they don't need any kind of License to
have an auction and this section of RSA
that we're working on is under the um
the
oplc the licensing organization for the
state and that this is a section about
uh this is this it's this is in the
auctioneer
um description of what somebody needs to
do to get a license to be an Auctioneer
and this
particular part of that that's being
amended the um 31b colon 13 is an a
section titled
exemptions so so the paragraph that
exists
before this the the paragraph two not
2A um refers what what it says there is
that members of the
organization don't need a license to be
an Auctioneer and to hold a charity
auction provided they have to be members
of that organization and they can they
um can't be members only for the purpose
of holding an auction so this particular
paragraph 2 a the language in that
pretty much mirrors the language in a
the difference is that this is new this
is being added and this is trying to say
that
um a person can be hired doesn't have to
be a member they can be hired to be an
an Auctioneer but it limits the normal
function of an Auctioneer pretty much to
just standing up there and say you know
who bids this who you know what kind of
bid can I get from you and not handling
the money and the custody of the
property and liability for what's you
know presented all of that stuff so that
makes sense um I was just trying to make
the correction that the organization
doesn't need a
license um it's it's not a that it's a
question of the auctioneer doesn't need
a license but as we got more into this
then turns out that the reference to RSA
2B it says so all of these organ
organizations have to be um eligible
under RSA 721 2B which if you look at it
um which is part of what um the GPT
thing is going to help you with is they
have to be a church or a re a religious
organization and talks about being a
denomination so you you know an
educational institution isn't going to
qualify as
that in addition if we're supposed to
need um the in
um if we need to
reference not just 721 2B if we need to
also U reference the USC statute which
which is also about churches and as far
as I could see they look pretty much
referring to the same thing then that
also needs to happen in the paragraph
above so you know what's going on here
so that's my my concern about this is
that this
is not ready for prime time and needs to
go back and clarify exactly who this is
supposed to be
for
represent thank you Mr chair I tend to
agree with representative fellows uh it
doesn't include several large charitable
organizations uh such as uh the Masons
the Lions the Kanas the uh
um elk the
Moose um Knights of Columbus um which
are all different
501c
organizations okay uh yeah just to
clarify 501c there are lots and lots of
different kind kinds of
three 501 C 501 3 there are less 501 see
yes and then the rest of it breaks it
down to many other categories some of
which are are Charities
5013c qualify as Charities the only one
that qualifies and the other ones are
all those other things so I I don't know
maybe if we had just 5013c in here that
would take care of it but I'm not I'm
it's too confusing and that's why I
think it needs to get fixed yes and and
that was my point because these other
organizations under New Hampshire law
are considered Charities because they do
New Hampshire law doesn't follow federal
law and it says that they're they do
charitable work uh and these other
organizations will often times run a
charity raffle a charity auction to
raise funds for the works that they do
so the the the issue is this needs some
additional work to make sure sure that
those Charities that operate and even
qualify for charitable gaming are not uh
excluded um what on line eight actually
well let me
see okay no I'll take that back repr um
represen in PL what's confusing to me
with the Senate
construction is that it's still not
clear to me uh that it's the individual
that doesn't have to hold a license you
could read that either the individual or
the charitable organization or a
religious organization so I would change
the
wording for that by putting a period on
Line2 for that organization put a period
say the individual does not have to hold
a license period so it's clear that it's
the individual that doesn't have to hold
the license rather than the charity and
with respect to uh represent ol's point
I I think our definition our our state
laws RSA 721 cover all those
organizations so not
but representative Ames would you like
to or should I come
back
um I I basically I think we are going to
need to take a little more time to sort
this out and it's just a drafting issue
I I don't think this is as complicated
as it's become um my sense
is for one thing I I'll start with uh
this paper that uh representative
fellow's handed out that has on it this
it's this chat CPT
3.5 and then there's an explanation of
the key elements of RSA 721
2B but that's just a partial statement
of what's in RSA
721 um so that uh if you look at 721
it's quite broad now I can't say for
sure the question it's going to be asked
about Masons and Elks and and so forth I
don't know I haven't had time to look at
it but uh um I kind of like I guess if I
looking at these three options as
drafted and uh and then uh
representative janigian and
representative fellows I like the
structure in uh in representative
janigian which was drafted I take it by
the attorney general in the teral trust
or at least it was it has his Blessing
right um and and uh it starts out with
an or an organization meeting the
definition of a charitable organization
da or the definition of a church da da
da may may engage an individual not
covered in paragraph two of this section
this is uh the section that deals with
licensing for
auctioneers uh May so so these
organizations that are charitable or
churches May engage an individual
uh who is not covered in paragraph two
of this section in other words not a
licensed Auctioneer to perform charity
auctions for that organization without
holding a license to me that's pretty
clear and um we just have to double
check and make sure that these
references are sufficiently
comprehensive so that we're not leaving
out inadvertently some subgroup that
should be in there well let me ask
represent excuse me representative
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman I
concur with uh what representative Ames
has just said I have no problem at all
with what the bill wants to do but I
think that the phrasing is
ambiguous I think I personally need to
look at the citations and read the
language more carefully before I'm
satisfied or
comfortable
particularly I think you can read these
three different versions and come down
uncertain whether the purpose is to
allow an unlicensed charitable
organization to hire a licensed
Auctioneer or second to allow an
organization to have its members be
unlicensed in this process
or to have an unlicensed Auctioneer now
my impression when we listened to
testimony in the hearing was we're not
talking about un unlicensed auctioneers
we're talking about an organization able
to hire an Auctioneer without the
organization needing a license so that
specific intent as to those three
possible interpretations needs to be
clarified and then get the syntax right
to nail it
down uh represent me yes on
representative oery it was actually when
we last had to deal with all of these
different kinds of Charities I think it
was at least eight years ago um there we
as I remember we killed her I asked the
bill and there was going to be a study
committee trying to make it work better
and it didn't
happen on I will say that my brain felt
like it was in a fog the whole
time so uh I don't think this is going
to be easy but if the legal Minds on our
committee could collaborate with each
other over email or something
and try to figure it
out we we've gotten till May
25 yeah no I I think um my sense right
now would be for representative
spillsbury and representative Ames to
work possibly with uh Michael of the
trust division to come up with language
that the three of you feel is
comprehensive uh because I think we
could go around and around in circles
right now most of us um not
being that familiar with this
representative
Ori thank thank you
um it's more comp more comprehensive
than just this particular bill there's a
several other bills that are out there
that we've actually heard a couple of
them this year um the def and we killed
one of them recently the definition of a
charity in New Hampshire is seems to be
either super broad or limited to 501
c3s and it's not entirely clear how that
operates and how that's going to to work
and I think that's the point that uh
representative am uh as excuse me um me
was starts with an A close enough it's
got an m in it too so that that may be
part of what they need to determine um
the intent is it do we do we just want
5013 C's or do we want a broader
definition that maybe partly what they
can uh help determine represent Aly yeah
there's another uh body that I had noted
that we ought to check with there is a
board of of
auctioneers and uh so we ought to check
with the oplc about this
too okay represent fellow so I just want
to say that based on where this is in
the statute it's very it's this is in
the
licensing statute it's the one that's
licensing an Auctioneer so it and it's
in a section that says exemptions so lot
you know to be an Auctioneer you have to
have all these certain
qualifications and then this particular
section of that um licensing says you
don't have to get have you you can do
auctioneering activities without a
license that's what this paragraph is
about so it's clearly it it's going into
the um the professional licensing
statutes so it's not licensing an
organization and that's that part is
clear I also like to would point out
that what we got from the sen Senate
says that this paragraph is about
charity auctions by
nonprofit and in the process of getting
additional um amendments done from for
this
um and in that act this is L um OSS made
changes to definition of what this this
act is about because that's their
prerogative you you can give them a
suggestion but they can change that part
that says an act in description of the
act so in in mine they changed it to
allowing certain Char charitable
organization in certain religious
organization ations to engage in
unlicensed
auctioneering
um organizations to engage an unlik
licensed auction Auctioneer who is not a
member of the organization and then in
um the chair's Amendment they changed it
to
say allowing certain charitable
organizations and certain religious
organizations to G
an unlicensed Auctioneer who is not a
resident of the organization but in both
of those two amendments that's clearly
significantly different than what came
from the sentence from the Senate that
says charity auctions by nonprofit
organizations which are
501c3 you at least as far as I know and
um churches and these two references are
not um automatically
501c3 and usually they're not 501 c3s so
this is
not
significant inconsistencies here yeah I
think at the end of the day we've got to
go back to the fact that there's there
this needs to be cleaned up and um I
think uh you know as as I said if
representative Ames and representative
spillsbury are willing to and obviously
taking input from anyone else but
primarily uh figure this out work with
Michael Haley come up with language that
clarifies
so I my perspective is this needs to go
back to the sponsors to find out exactly
what their intent was and
that um that needs to be clarified
before the charity Bureau can can
identify what statutes need to be
referenced
because using that they have to fall
under these two the RSA and the US um
statute us um code that this is only
about churches and religious
organizations and it leaves out all the
other things that are that are nonprofit
the food food bank you know New
Hampshire Food Bank tons and tons of
nonprofit private schools often hold U
ch um you know Charities for their
operating funds or for the building fund
you know that's that's would say
representative PL I just looked up RSA
721b okay and it says charitable
organization shall mean the following
any person or entity is determined by
the IRS to be ATT tax exemp organization
pursuant section 501c3 of the Internal
Revenue code as that section now exists
or may thereafter be amended or this is
the or is important any other person or
entity that is or holds itself out to be
established in whole or aart for any
benevolent philanthropic patriotic
educational Humane scientific Public
Health Environmental Conservation Civic
or other charitable purpose or any
person who in any uh you get the picture
I just blew up but but it covers
everybody so yeah that's so that's
exactly the point that I think the chair
is attempting to make it's both and
neither so can I just ask what exactly
what he was quoting because that doesn't
match up with what I
found uh well he
I can do that I say 72 721b yeah I I I
just think
uh one at a time seven hyphen excuse me
seven what's it dot on dot colon uh 21
definitions and then under
B this is this one referred to it
is what representative
names well you know it's clearly
confusion so I don't know we we need to
take this off and and fix it up but uh
the the document uh that you passed out
representative fellos that explains the
key elements of RSA 721 2B is
incomplete it doesn't have the whole
statute there that's not the
statute I think you know in part of of
uh representative Ames and
representative spillsbury working on
this it's to
also understanding you know the purpose
the the purpose and also what the RSA is
referring to here actually do so that
you can come up with a comprehensive
solution so I think at this point we'
beat this one to death and uh we will uh
I will close exe I'm sorry the work
session on uh s SP
513 thank you assume we don't exec
needed that one
like yeah we I think it's pretty obvious
we will not be executing uh SP 513 this
afternoon okay last but not least I will
open the work session on
s514 and um representative PL you have
your hand up yes I did uh I have no
problem with this bill it's it's the uh
uh revenues uh by
increasing uh the uh amount of wood and
whatever form that can be taken for
personal use uh not subject to Timber
tax the the revenue impact of that is di
Minimus uh and uh to use the word yeah
to use the word Dom Minimus yeah or it
doesn't amount to squat is this it's
another way of putting the same thing
it's 200 bucks a year maybe to an
average municipality and $5 increments
and it's more hassle than it's
worth thank
you anybody else here than you represent
okay we have agreement there um I guess
we can move on I don't see any other
questions or concerned so I'll close the
work session on S SP
514 okay now um we're I want to uh break
and have um exact uh I mean caucuses or
at least U
I'm sure both sides may want to have a
caucus before we get to the exec session
but the time being 20 of 12 the probably
it makes sense to put lunch in there as
well unless people are against that U
but I think I'd rather starve to death
you'd rather starve to death okay um I'd
rather plow ahead what do you want have
lunch so
we why don't we
um
well no we we're we're going to have at
least one caucus
um so I guess it's 20 of 12
um we come back I think why don't we
come back at
what well we gonna have lunch or not I
mean do what do people want to do do you
want to have lunch or I mean
historically
are how many people want to just have a
Cox come back at 12 and try to exec
these okay I think
uh that's what we will
do all right so uh we will uh start the
exec session uh at 12
o' I would ask everyone um to leave the
room please except Republicans and we'll
have a caucus
here members Republican members
committee
members I just got
that
e
all right the time being
12:04 we'll get started on our executive
sessions first up I'll open the exact
session on SB
324 and recognize representative PL for
a motion yes I move ought to pass on SB
324 an adoption of amendment 1310
H uh wait a minute first first we have
ought to pass okay do I have a
second second by rep representative
Southworth somewhere in the corner
there okay I can't even see you when I
when I move back and forth
here uh representative PL I move
adoption of amendment number what did
they say
1310 is
that let's make sure that's the right
one okay do I have a second on
1310 second I have to do a second line
then
okay yeah because is a second motion
second okay
um are you ready would you like to speak
to um your Amendment the
amendment took care of concerns that we
heard during hearing on this bill uh we
heard from the uh Lottery Commission
that uh some of their licenses a small
percentage are monthly or quarterly and
they couldn't handle this so they wanted
to make sure it applied only to annual
licenses and the rewarding takes care of
that at least 45 days prior to the
explanation of an annual license issued
in accordance with this chapter the
commission shall notify the lcy leny of
the pending expiration ex and then they
refer to uh they follow have to follow
law anyway under RSA 541a 29 and 30 this
just makes us explicit the commission
shall conduct such suspensions
revocations in accordance with RSA 54183
when we here during the work session
they had no problem with this
amendment other
discussion okay seeing none uh the clerk
will call the role on the
amendment
all
right
uh represent ducet yes representative
erery yes representative Boyd yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative Vose yes
representative kahill yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth
yes representative Malloy yes
representative shanberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative
leapley yes and represent Smith is not
here okay uh the chair yes okay so the
vote is 19 to zero one not voting on the
amendment okay the uh Amendment passes
now on to the otpa motion I move otpa Mr
chair okay um any questions any
seconds U where got okay second by
represent
Southworth okay seeing no more
discussion um I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on
otpa okay
okay uh representative duet yes
representative erery yes representative
Boyd yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representa ORS
yes representative o
yes representative Cahill yes
representative Aly yes representative
Ames yes represent Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes represent LE leapley yes
and the chair
yes the vote is
uh make sure I did that right uh is it
should be 19 uh Z One voting but I
screwed up the C so give me a second
that's because it's everything's out of
order there's my
mistake 10 the vote being 19 to zero any
objection to consent 17 seeing none put
it on the consent calendar
okay
and I'll close the ex session for S SP
324 now open the exec session for S SP
363 and
recognize representative erery I'm mile
ought to
pass do I have a
second second by representative Aly okay
I'm not quite all right we'll give you
10 more seconds
thank you for your
generosity okay we are on
to
OTP 33 26
24 okay and the motion was made
by um
was representative
ery and seconded by representative
Aly
okay okay uh would you like to speak to
your motion represent
ering Mr Speaker how many more no um
just I haven't been promoted to speaker
I was I was quoting a statement made on
the US House Flor excuse me
um it's for the dogs yeah
I mean
seriously what what are you going to say
on this but thank
you any other discussion following such
audite conversation represent Aly is
that going to be the
report I don't think so no we won't
accept that as the full report okay Mr
uh chair I am putting something in the
report about uh Steve banord
and uh animal abuse not that Steve was
involved in animal abuse but he helped
stop it okay all right thank you um the
clerk will call the
role okay I'm ought to pass on uh bill
number 363 which is a simultaneous
simultan dog racing representative duet
chairman Vice chairman do set okay yes
uh representative erery yes
representative Boyd yes represent
spillsbury
yes represent PL votes yes represent
sodi yes represent ORS yes represent V
yes representative kill yes
representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamber yes representative fellos yes
representative Bolton yes represent of
elberger yes represent of leapley yes
okay uh and the
chair yes so it's 19 there zero one not
voting the vote being 19 to zero any
objection to consent seeing none we'll
put that on consent as
well and I'll close the exact session
for
I'll now open the exec session on SB
473 and
recognize representative PL when he's
got to I move L to
passille 473 FN do I have a
second second by representative
Southworth okay and would you like to
speak to your yes um were we to get an
amendment on this before we exect it we
do it's on your thank you I just didn't
register it the the process I have to
move L to pass one a second and then I
move the amendment that's what I'm about
to but we fixed the language about where
the money goes thank you very much
representative PL did uh you want to
speak to the motion or did you want to
make i' rather spoke to the I'd rather
make move an amendment I want to make
sure I have the right amendment number
here that was my hope 1332 H I think y
okay okay so I I move the amendment 1332
H yeah and do I have a second on 1332
h represent Southworth I could have done
that on the same line but that's
okay okay represent PL if you would
speak to your Amendment please yes uh
after hashing it out this this morning
uh we we wound up with some
compromises
uh so uh this
uh we we we took a sentence out which uh
so that the money unclaimed ticket money
uh is not specified to a special cause
it's so it's following existing law
which is what I understand
representative Aly wanted in the
commission the the the group as a whole
supported uh so it shall be forwarded to
the Lottery Commission and uh we add of
the sentence back in uh such money shall
become a part of the special fund
established an RSA 28421
J and I think that took care of the
concerns this morning
yes and I think that was to make sure it
went into the education trust fund point
of order will they correct the spelling
of
monies oh where it's minor but I think
they
correct what line is that in I'm sorry
it jumped right out at me and now
special line 10
Yes actually it could be taken that way
with a cap a plural either way yeah okay
any
discussion seeing
none I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll just one
second
1332 h on the amendment yeah yeah but I
have to put the bill number two no
that's fine take your
time okay this is an amendment number I
can't read my own writing 1332 H uh 326
24 I'll call the role in the amendment
uh representative
ducet yes representative uh erer yes
representative Boyd yes representative
spillsbury yes representative PL votes
yes representative sodi yes
representative or yes representative
Vose yes representative uh uh Cahill yes
representative Aly yes representative
Ames yes represent Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes represent fellows yes
represent Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Le leapley
yes and the chair yes okay 19 to zero
one not
voting okay representative PL would you
like to make a additional motion I move
to ought to pass as amended for uh for
um 473
FN and representative Southworth do you
will you second that yeah as
well
okay any discussion on
otpa seeing none the clerk will call the
role
FN
otpa
uh chairman duet yes represent erery yes
represent Boyd yes represent spillsbury
yes represent PL votes yes
representative sodi yes represent ORS
yes representative V yes representative
kahill yes representative
Aly representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes Representative shanberg no
okay representative fellow
yes representative Bolton
yes okay representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes and the chair
yes so the vote is 18 yes one no and one
not
voting is there an objection to consent
there is not okay we'll put that on
consent
I'll close the uh exec session on S SP
473 I'm going to open the exec session
on SB
454 and recognize representative
spillsbury for a motion thank you Mr
chair I move is interim study on S SP
454 and do I have a
second
second representative fellows did you
representative fellows will second
it
okay do we have any
discussion um and represent spilsbury
would you like to speak to your motion
that gives me time yes thank you I think
we had a very balanced discussion this
morning I think there was generally a
consensus that the timing isn't right
but we shouldn't foreclose the option we
can wait and see what the Senate does
and have a better sense of what our
Revenue availability is so itum study is
the right way of setting it aside but
not putting it to
bed thank you is there any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role okay this is on
vote motion of interim study in 454 FN
Vice chairman duet yes uh representative
erery yes representative Boyd yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative Vose yes
representative kahill
yes represent of
Aly no represent of Ames no
represent of Southworth no represent
Malloy no represent shanberg no
represent fellows
yes represent Bolton no represent
elberger no Representative leapley
no uh the chairman
yes so the vote is
108 and one not voting 10 to eight no 11
to8 where I screw up one got to be 11
yeah 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 that's where I
screwed up 11
11 to uh eight and one uh one not voting
and excuse me but I'm having to bounce
all over out of order because of this
sheet well forgive
me
huh yes you're doing a good job
fr done okay so this uh not going on
consent not going on consent and uh
who's writing the who's writing The
Minority Report leapley leapley is
writing The Minority
Report okay I we'll close the exact
session on sb45
four we'll now open the exec session on
SP
497 and recognize representative Aly for
a
motion thank you um I move uh Senate
Bill
497 with Amendment do I have well wait a
minute do I have a second yeah a to pass
on on a to pass
497 second by representative
bolon uh represent Aly would you like to
make a further motion yes I
move there it is amendment uh 1294
h on to SB
497 do I have a second on
that representative
Southworth
and would you like to speak to your
Amendment representative
Aly um
it's pretty simple this is something
that um we have
to um get done to um be in compliance
with the
federal on uh requirements on federally
on disproportionate share Hospital
examinations uh to is something I'd
never heard of used instead of
inspections but um or
calculations but
um and the amendment is is necessary
because it the original language
completion of was not uh precise
enough okay um any other comments on
that representative Ames did you have a
okay um all right so uh then we will
vote on the amendment the clerk will
call the
role yes Mr chair this is amendment
number 1294 H um and starting with Vice
chairman deset yes representative erery
yes representative Boy Yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes represent ORS
yes representative Vose yes
representative k
yes represent
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representa shamber yes
represent fellos yes represent Bolton
yes represent elberger yes represent
leapley
yes the chair
yes the vote is 19 to zero one not
voting on the amendment
okay um represent Aly did you have a
further motion yes and I move Senate
Bill 497 FN as amended by uh Amendment
1294 H do I have a second ought to pass
sorry as amended I'll second second by
representative Bolton represent Aly
would you like to speak to your
motion uh
I think I said
it I was thinking the
same okay seeing no
further conversation on otpa I will ask
the clerk to call the
role this is otpa and 497 representative
duet yes represent
erery yes representative Boyd yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes yes represent
ORS yes representative Vose yes
representative Cahill yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes repres shamberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative
leapley yes and the chair yes vot is 19
to zero one not
voting
without objection this will go on
consent
okay and
uh I will close the exact session on SP
497 53 and 513 we are skipping we will
not exec that as per our work session
we'll there'll be further work on
that so that brings up again last but
not least uh the exec session for S SP
514 and I'll open that
now and I will rep recognize
representative shamberg from motion
thank you Mr chair uh make a motion to
OTP on Senate Bill
514 and speak to my motion do I have a
second representative sod seconds
it and would you like to speak to your
motion yes Mr chair uh what this bill
does is increase the volume of Timber
eligible for personal use and land
conversion Timber tax exemptions within
the timber tax law and has a dimin dimin
effect upon the revenue stream to the
communities well said it's different
than what representative duet wanted me
to say thank
you um any other
comments seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the
role representative deset yes
representative deset rather you you said
yes representative janigian excuse me
representative Boyd yes representative
oler yes representative spilsbury yes
represent pled votes yes representative
sodi yes representative ores yes
representative Vose yes representative
kill yes representative uh
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes represent shanberg yes
representative fellows yes repres
represent Bolton yes represent elberger
yes representative leapley
yes and the chair yes so the vote is
1901 not voting on ought to pass on SP
54 seeing no uh are there any objections
to consent seeing none we will also put
this on the consent
calendar
okay good job uh I'm glad we didn't go
to lunch first
uh well done uh thank you everybody so
next week um as per the email that IID
sent earlier about reserving uh time I
will schedule a meeting
for um Tuesday of next week um really
the only items we well let me first ask
representative spillsbury and Ames do
you think by
next is next week too early to have
feedback on uh five 13 or yes represent
spills I certainly think it's possible
um
but just a matter of zeroing and
focusing on it my question is how many
additional Senate bills have we already
got in our docket so that that that yeah
therein lies what I'm trying to figure
out right now there's only two other
there's only only two Senate bills that
have been added to our uh docket so far
and um they um so I was planning on
seeing how things went today and and
finishing up any execs next week and
then doing the two public
hearings but that's all we really have
right now it's two public hearings and
possibly
513 given that we've acted on six out of
seven have only two new ones and have
plenty of time maybe we don't even need
to meet next week and and wait for the
final uh wave of bills from the Senate
yeah we probably don't really need to
meet next week unless somebody feels
that we
do
mys okay I think we're I think we're
doing great I think we're we're moving
along very nicely so I will not schedule
anything for next week that brings us to
the week after when I I had said to
reserve Monday and Tuesday of the week
after probably it's only going to we're
only going to Pro and I and I'll focus
more on a Tuesday because I notice I
know people try to schedule things on
Mondays and Fridays um unless we get a
barrage of Senate bills um I don't
anticipate meeting more than whatever
what is that date of the following week
the the 9th Tuesday Tuesday the 9th so
so I guess for right now probably
Tuesday the 9th we'll try to exec maybe
s SP
513 um representative Ames and
spillsbury kind of keep in mind that so
two weeks from now we'll try to exec
5113 and then we'll have public hearings
on uh the Senate bills that are at least
the two and any any new ones that come
in uh at that time so representative uh
Aly yeah on the 11th is
crossover and we'll probably get any
most Senate bills that we would get then
after that okay which would mean two
weeks
away um but I guess so you're oh you're
saying we we might only still have two
sen Senate bills at that time maybe
three I don't know yeah um well let's
Okay let me look at the calendar so
you're you're proposing is you won't
know until until Thursday so yeah that
that's why I'm saying leave so we won't
meet next week it sounds like there's no
need to
um
but leave open Tuesday the night I mean
probably only need one day I I don't
know that we need to reserve the eth
unless someone thinks I'm missing
something um it's a little bit F let's
give it a little more time but I think
it's only going to be the 9th we will
not tely plan on the eth as well but as
soon as I have further I'm
saying oh you're saying 10 n so we might
not meet till yeah
not we got two pieces so we dispatched
454 was the one was the one that needed
that was the only early bill that's done
so um yeah it's it's possible we might
not meet until Tuesday the
16th um
okay T TBD but for now we're not meeting
next week the week of the 1 um but
continue to leave open
um the 9th I don't think we need the eth
just leave open the
9th okay thank you any other yes
represent elberger so I just want to
confirm nothing next week right let's
skip you're cancelling Monday the 8th
yes I don't think we need Monday
and if we meet on the 9th we'd be
executing
first
um and the reason I'm asking is working
around a doctor's appointment yeah
um there's only one bill yeah there'd
only be one bill to exact and that would
be
5113 I don't suspect
it and that but that would be the first
item that we would do um it doesn't have
to be it would be easier oh that's your
problem um pleas the only reason for
well no I guess you don't know how long
public hearings go either
um yeah we could probably
exec uh that any Tuesday meeting starts
at 10: in difference to the Democratic
caucus who's not available till 10: so
we could exect that at 10 o'clock if we
if we decide to do it on the
night it's possible that we won't meet
that week of the 8th and 9th either but
for now I would say leave the ninth open
just in case I do get a barrage of
tennis tenant tenis right Senate bills
in it would have to be a barrage of the
uh early of early bills from the
Senate um because uh we've got until May
16th for the rest of
them there's a good chance we won't meet
on the ninth either but but leave it
Reserve for
now yeah there's no need to reserve the
eth the more I'm thinking about it so
um
okay any other questions uh oh the last
thing is just reports those of you who
have a report to write um you don't you
don't need to write it now before you
leave um and I think the preference my
preference would be to have it rather
than write it out on a sheet of paper to
to email it to me electronically because
for two reasons one is if there's
anything that needs to be changed on it
it's easier to change but it's also heck
of a lot easier for Karen not to have to
uh read writing and and so forth so
especially with my writing which is
abysmal I was mainly thinking no I'm
just kidding
U um so in terms of timing of that if
you can obviously for the count it's not
critical because we have time but if you
if you can get them in um before noon
time on
Wednesday or or sooner if you get it in
tonight or by say noon time Wednesday
great if you just absolutely can't do it
uh then by the end of the week but I
would my preference would be sooner than
later there's nothing else any other
questions I think we're yes represent
fellows yes I'm wondering if we could
get some research on um 597 the new one
coming up rout relative to the Lucky
Seven
tickets because it seems to me I think
we passed something last year related to
that and I just wanted to be able to
compare I don't I don't even know if
what we passed last
year actually I don't know but I mean
obviously it'll start with a public
hearing and and Lottery being here um
they probably would be an immense help
in that regard and um then schedule work
sessions as appropriate to get
additional info
unless there I mean if there's something
specific that you'd like to get you
could request request it but for now not
knowing what bill it is or anything okay
they may answer all those questions all
right anybody
else okay thank you good work
today like we just keep getting the same
things
for